[Music]
straight ahead
on lawn crime daily the family of a
college student missing for two decades
now suing the father of her alleged
murderer
why kristen smart's parents think ruben
flores knows where the remains of their
daughter is
and the u.s supreme court ruling
changing courses
on how juvenile offenders are sentenced
should minors convicted of murder
automatically be sentenced to life in
prison without parole
plus i am guilty the ohio man
admitting his family killed eight
members of another family
in the pike county massacre and we speak
to the family of george floyd
about the funeral of dante wright two
families quest for justice in minnesota
helping changing
seeing the light that we didn't see
before law and crime
daily covering court cases from coast to
coast
and welcome to long prime daily
everybody i'm jesse weber in for brian
buckmeyer
along with co-host terry austin the 20
year old man
killed by a police officer near
minneapolis during the derek chauvin
trial was laid to rest
brian buckmeyer was at his funeral for
us and has the latest
days after the trial where derrick
shoven was convicted for murdering
george floyd
we went to a funeral for dante wright at
the funeral many members of his family
spoke his mother his father
his siblings as well as reverend al
sharpton
and attorney benjamin crump they spoke
about justice
accountability and the life of dante
wright
when he walked in the room he lit up the
room he was a
brother a jokester he was
loved by so many he's going to be so
missed
we also saw somewhat of an
indoctrination
into this fraternity of individuals who
have lost loved ones
at the hands of police the family of
philando castile was there
the family of george floyd was there
kenneth walker was there
the family of emmett till were there
everyone who has been touched in a
similar way
in loss and love was there to show
support
for the family of dante wright
afterwards we had the opportunity to
speak with george floyd's
uncle who spoke about being an activist
not only for his
nephew george floyd but for all people
the verdict
we got the one that we needed did we get
the charge that we needed
no but hey listen to something you know
he don't get to walk around anymore
for the first time we finally get an
opportunity
to see that we can win this battle and
fix this battle but the momentum my
nephew gave us
had his death it's pretty good we
we had a jump start you know and as long
as we keep on fighting the way we're
fighting and
people get their head up and just make
good decisions we will be okay
now the family in the community is
looking for justice as they seek
a guilty verdict from former officer kim
potter but they're saying that
manslaughter is not enough
they're looking for higher charges and
will push for those charges
as well as greater justice for their
community and their country abroad
all right thanks brian derek chauvin
could be facing
federal criminal charges on top of his
state conviction
long crimes anjanet levy's here with the
latest turn in this case
angenette well jesse this is an
interesting development that's come out
abc news is reporting that department of
justice sources are telling
them that they're looking into another
incident involving derek chauvin
in which he pinned a boy to the ground a
17 year old boy
with his knee prosecutors say body
camera footage shows derrick chauvin
kneeling on the boy's back
for 17 minutes police were called to the
boy's house after his mother said she
was assaulted by him
and her daughter the boy reportedly was
laying on the ground when officers
arrived and would not get
up two seconds later chauvin grabbed the
child's throat and hit him again in the
head with his flashlight
the boy cried out mom and appeared to
lose consciousness
he awoke about a minute later and said
he couldn't breathe as
chauvin kneeled on him there's also a
civil investigation
underway by the department of justice
into the practices of the minneapolis
police
it's something activists here have been
asking for
for years we reminded them of their
what their their purpose was we let them
know that
they're that there are people here that
are hurting that there's people here who
are
who are dying and we most importantly
let them know that we needed their help
and they needed to be right here with
the people
as part of that civil probe federal
investigators will be looking for input
from the public
that investigation could take as long as
two years
jesse thanks angeannette now let's break
it down with us is retired nypd
detective and new york law school
professor kirk burkhalter
and terry austin terry the state
attempted to admit the september 2017
incident during the trial phase of the
case it wasn't but
do you think that this incident will be
raised during the sentencing phase of
the case
i do jesse because they have wider
ladder to doing the sentencing phase and
the last thing the judge asked about was
i want you to give me the aggregating
factors and of course he's going to
consider
the mitigating factors because he's
going to be looking at the
sentencing guidelines and i think that
when he looks at all of those factors he
looks at what has happened in children's
history
he's going to consider everything in at
the end of the day
i believe he's going to impose the
maximum that he
possibly can under minnesota law which
is
that second degree murder count up to 40
years
it may be less than that but i think
he's going to try to get as much as he
can
now professor what charges could chovin
potentially face for the 2017
incident and does the guilty verdicts in
floyd's case affects this at all
well and on the federal level this would
be a deprivation of civil rights
and what we have seen is these cases are
difficult to bring
against police officers however derek
chavin is a
different animal because you already
have this pattern of behavior
so if you can use the the problem with
the floyd
with the death of george floyd the floyd
case is that
this occurred after he uh did this
allegedly to this child so may not be
able to come in usually you'll see some
type of prior act
come in to show a pattern all right and
angela real quick
what's the feeling amongst activists
about this civil investigation
i think they're hopeful but also
skeptical
they will tell you if you speak with
them that they the justice department
was here back in 2016
at their request and they arranged
meetings between the activists and the
police department there were working
groups
but the activists say any reforms that
came up or were outlined in paperwork
were put on in a file
and it never went anywhere so they're
hopeful and they say this time they want
less talk
and more action well i think we all knew
that those
guilty verdicts wasn't going to be the
end of the story and it's going to be a
story we continue to follow
still ahead on long crime daily a new
lawsuit in the case of missing college
student kristin
smart an update to this year long saga
but first a major break in ohio's
largest murder case
the deadly custody battle and why a man
says he's flipping on his own family
when we come back
[Music]
welcome back everybody a major
development in ohio's largest
ever murder investigation one of the
four people charged in the pike county
massacre admits he
and his family committed the crimes and
jeannette levy's back with the latest in
this saga angenette
jesse for many years jake wagner and
members of his family
have vehemently denied any involvement
in the rodent and gilly murders
but now that has changed
yes your honor i agree to what the state
has provided
and i am deeply and very sorry on the
fifth anniversary of the rhoden and
gilly murders
jake wagner stood in a pike county
courtroom and
admitted he and his family killed the
eight family members
including the mother of his child hannah
may rhoden
what plead you wish to get her in count
seven to the charge of aggravated murder
of hannah mayweather
i am guilty of your honor wagner
appeared to tear up when hannah may's
name was mentioned
prosecutors say wagner his mother angela
father billy and older brother george
wanted full custody of the little girl
hannah and jake shared he recently
confessed to state investigators after
years of denying involvement what he
told us
led us to discover some evidence that
had yet to be recovered
specifically the weapons that were used
in these offenses
along with vehicles that were used
during these offenses including one that
was bought specifically to use the night
of the homicide
wagner and his family were indicted in
november 2018
after a two and a half year
investigation that included pleas from
geneva rhoden
the matriarch of the family i'd just
like to say
from my mother's heart
that i hurt so bad
inside
from the day that i found out at the
start of the investigation there were
few leads
then investigators attention turned to
the wagners a year after the murders
this was cold cold cold blood i mean
this was calculated
planned out ohio governor mike dewine
was the attorney general when the
murders happened
that day he promised the rodents the
case would be solved
family's been through hell while today
i'm sure was a very gratifying day it
couldn't have been an easy day
they've got to be leaving here just
totally exhausted and you know
emotionally spent
but these are tough people these are
strong people
and as part of the plea agreement jake
wagner has actually agreed to testify
against his mother his father and his
older brother
and the death penalty as part of the
plea agreement has been taken
off of the table for all of them jesse
wow uh all right thanks and jeanette
let's bring back in our panel uh
professor so
wagner pleads guilty the death penalty
is taken off the table apparently for
all them
is that justice i guess it depends on
your view
of whether the death penalty is an
appropriate penalty at any point
i will say it may be justice for the
family because it could possibly
save them the pain of a very long trial
with all types of testimony that would
be wildly uncomfortable for them
so it very well might be you know terry
how do you think jake wagner's guilty
plea is going to affect the cases
against his other family members you
talk about family drama my gosh
absolutely you know i think this is
really obviously going to help the
prosecution because
they initially were going off in
tangents now they have someone
who is cooperating they have someone who
can give them specific
evidence they don't have to worry about
getting this conviction because
clearly he is talking and he is going to
confess as far as the others are
concerned so
i think it's going to save the state
money i think it's going to save
both families obviously time to deal
with this issue
and it's going to help the community
because for many years people have been
wondering
what is going to happen in this case it
was one of the most horrific crimes i
think anyone has seen this was
a huge massacre and to have everything
solved now i think is really going to
help all around
and i know you've been following this
case and the governor said
this was well planned what do we know
about that and also
why did wagner decide to confess
well first of all part of the reason the
governor says it was so well planned was
because
the wagners apparently according to jake
and according to the
state agents had hacked into the
facebook accounts
of some of the rodents and actually had
we're monitoring them
in their homes through surveillance
cameras so this was
very well planned from the aspect that
hannah rhoden
in a tech in a facebook message months
prior to the murders
said to somebody to get my child they're
going to have to kill me first
and then after that the governor and the
state agents say that
wagner said they began to plan the
murders they bought bullets they bought
shoes they bought guns
they bought vehicles so and wagner says
he found god
that is why he confessed to the murders
wow classic okay in this case it just
keeps on coming
all right coming up on long crime daily
the new supreme court ruling
making it easier to sentence juveniles
to spend their lives in prison
plus the trial of the only officer
charged in the
brianna taylor case now delayed we'll
tell you why
coming up
[Music]
new u.s supreme court ruling will pave
the way to make it easier for juveniles
to be sentenced to life in prison
without the possibility of parole
the nation's highest court ruled six to
three that juveniles don't have to be
found to be beyond rehabilitation
to receive the maximum sentence it's
part of the state of mississippi
versus brett jones jones was convicted
and sentenced to life in prison without
parole
for stabbing his grandfather to death
when jones was 15 years old
jones was arguing that he was not beyond
rehabilitation
and should be eligible for parole the
state of mississippi said
the eighth amendment which protects
against cruel and unusual punishments
doesn't require that burden in 2005 the
supreme court abolished the death
penalty for minors
and in 2012 ruled that life without
parole sentences for juvenile offenders
should only be in the rarest occasions
justice brett kavanaugh
wrote the majority opinion issued
thursday saying it was enough that the
judge presiding over jones case
exercised discretion rather than
automatically applying
life without parole okay
professor legally how did the court come
to this decision what was the
justification
well to be quite frank the justification
is that the eighth amendment
does not state that the internment of
juveniles
for life is cruel and unusual punishment
this is an interpretation
of the united states constitution and an
interpretation of how the law has been
applied so
quite simply it depends on whether
you're a right-leaning judge or
a left-leaning judge as to whether the
law has been applied here or whether you
have the power to do so
the discretion still lies with the lower
court and that's what the court is
saying
so it's a very interesting decision and
it's interesting you talked about it on
uh
political lines because terry justice
sona mayor
justice sonia sotomayor wrote a scathing
descent
what did you think of her opinion what
did she say i actually agreed with her
opinion and she wrote that on behalf of
the other you know
left-leaning justices and that would be
briar and kagan
and what she said is that the court had
in the past been
recognizing the fact that children are
constitutionally
different from adults for the purposes
of sentencing and that 2012 case you
mentioned jesse
it really said that the constitution
should be a bar
for children being punished for
mandatory sentences
like that if it's cruel and unusual
punishment and
one of the things she mentioned in her
dissent was that 70
of all youth who receive this sentence
are children of color so it makes you
really want to think about
what the criminal justice system is
doing as far as applying these standards
it's an interesting decision and it's
also going to be interesting to see how
it ultimately
plays out when we come back the family
of kristin smart filing
a new lawsuit and new allegations will
the remains of the missing college
student ever be found
stay tuned
welcome back everybody we want to tell
you about our latest show on the long
crime network
called prime crime it's part two of our
story on samuel little
the most prolific serial killer in
united states history
we get into his background motivation
psychology
relationships with women and we also ask
the people who
interviewed little what was it like to
sit across
from a murderer i'll just say that when
you see his hands
you'll see just how monstrous they are
he may still
murder that person even though he was 70
years of age he felt he could get away
with it he would
did you ever shoot any of these girls
shoot yeah with a gun
on my hands just your hands and without
that i wouldn't want to do it
plus how investigators are confirming
his killings
and is he responsible for more deaths
that we don't know about
tune in to law on crime well let's
focus right now on the trial for the
former louisville officer charged in the
briana taylor case because that has been
delayed until 2022
brett hankinson is facing three felony
charges of wanton endangerment for
shooting into a nearby apartment
during a raid on taylor's home last
march no one is
charged with taylor's death and the
judge previously denied a motion by the
defense to change the trial to another
county
now that same judge is agreeing to
postpone this trial that was scheduled
for
this september until february of next
year
i believe so uh as i said looking ahead
to who i have in custody to be tried
whose trials have been delayed because
of the pandemic
i think february 1st is the most
realistic date that i have that does be
fun
okay all right then we will take um
the case off of the docket for august
31st
and reschedule the trial to february the
first
over now to california with the family
of a college student missing since 1996
is now suing the father of her alleged
murderer
cal poly state university student
kristin smart seemingly vanished 24
years ago after leaving a party
her ex-classmate paul flores is now
charged with murdering her
his father ruben flores is charged as an
accessory for allegedly helping to hide
smart's body
smart's body has yet to be recovered but
her parents are now alleging in a
lawsuit
that ruben flores removed her remains
from his home
just days after the san luis obispo
county sheriff's department served him a
search warrant now that was happened
that past february
smart's parents are suing for severe
emotional distress
and let's talk about it uh professor how
will this civil
lawsuit affect the criminal case and
vice versa
i'm always a little skeptical uh because
when you see this occur
usually you see the civil case follow
the criminal case because the standard
of proof
the bar is lower so i wonder if this has
something to do with a certain
lack of faith or whatever and the
prosecution as far as how it will affect
the case
once again it might create a little bit
of a problem because of the
testimony and evidence that is presented
in the civil case
prosecution will not have the first bite
at the apple so to speak so that would
be uh
uh interesting to watch to see how that
develops yeah
now terry so kristen smart's family is
suing for
severe emotional distress have you seen
this before and
what are the uh chances for recovery
with this kind of claim
you know jesse it is fairly common to
sue for
intentional infliction of emotional
distress it's a torque claim
and i think their chances of recovery
are high i mean you only have to show
that the defendant intended to inflict
this distress or
it was reckless and that the conduct
itself was outrageous and that it did in
fact cause emotional distress
and there's no question that there has
been emotional distress
usually you have to prove that distress
with medical records etc
but i think the parents are going to be
able to prove it just with their
testimony
and hopefully they will be able to
recover the question is
will there be funds to recover we talk
about the civil case
the criminal case i think at the end of
the day we all agree can we get more
answers about what happened to this
missing girl that's really where we're
all starting there
professor terry thank you so much and
everyone out there thanks for joining us
here
on long crime daily we're going to see
you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you